also multiple teams reportedly
interested in
panthers quarterback teddy bridgewater
if he takes a pay cut that was our
reaction
immediately to the news that sam darnold
is in carolina you have 10 million fully
guaranteed for bridgewater
17 million salary i think something in
the neighborhood of 12 is the magic
number
right he could go to denver and
compete with drew locke he could go to
san francisco
and be a much cheaper alternative to
jimmy garoppolo
and also avoid the possibility of a wait
for it
schism in the locker room between the
pro garoppolo crowd and the pro mac
jones or whoever comes in at number
three crowd which i'm sure kyle shanahan
doesn't want
there are plenty of places where if you
could get teddy bridgewater for 12
or thereabouts you'd be willing to do it
and
you know the panthers may have to pay
some of the 10. there could be a little
ryan tannehill factor
in all this yeah the salary's 12 but
a certain amount of it's going to be
paid by the panthers because there's 10
million fully guaranteed that they're
going to have to eat
if they can't unload this guy don't be
surprised if at the end of the day
the panthers are writing a check in part
to get teddy bridgewater off their
roster yeah
i mean it makes sense i hear that i mean
of course i would think teddy
bridgewater is going to have to lower
his price
if he wants to go to a you know another
team
and and be in a situation where he wants
to be in denver makes the most sense i
mean there's
there's no doubt about that you know
that seems to be
just the things you hear about the
broncos seems to make the most sense as
far as what they would want to
you know again just a guy that's there
that's you know hey drew you can't you
can't slip
up you can't this is every practice you
know every practice got to be pretty
perfect this is quarterback in the nfl
you know that's that's you know that's
what happens with young quarterbacks or
young players in the nfl in general
they're just not used to the
every play i got to be on it what do you
mean i can't
ever mess up a play in a game or
anything no you can't that that can ruin
the game
sorry this is not college anymore and
yeah
that would be perfect from that aspect
and if he did course start and melt down
teddy could come in
and and right the ship a little bit and
play the right way to
you know at least manage games and do
all that we need
odds for the next bridgewater
destination because i would say broncos
are the favorite yeah i'd say the 49ers
are on the board as well
i got you i would i would put the
seahawks i would put the seahawks in
play
i hear you given the lingering
possibility right russell wilson
and i'd put the buccaneers on there
because if all else fails and the
panthers can't find a good destination
and he won't take a pay cut see
if if if he knows that tampa bay is
holding the number two spot for him
he doesn't have to take any pay cut he
just says no no want to be traded there
you gotta take a pay cut no
no no i'll take my 10 million and i'll
go to tampa bay
and i'll i'll try to set myself up to be
the successor to tom brady and i don't
think that can that possibility can be
ignored chris
no i i mean i i hear you there i i do
you know
tampa's another team that's interesting
as far as drafting a quarterback i know
there's been that talk
out there you know maybe they'll try to
find the replacement the future guy
all of that um they do have bla i mean
blaine gabbard i believe is he still
under contract there
is the backup quarterback i'm not sure i
know he's not like you know
hasn't played a lot and a guy you're
gonna depend on i just i'm just
thinking of the situation in general uh
but that makes i think he may be a free
agent
he's a free agent but i know after that
i think you hit
all the teams that that makes sense to
me
after that i can't see any others right
now where i look at and go
um yeah this maybe this one too i think
we've we've kind of hit them all
blaine gabbard is an unrestricted free
agent he had a
a contract that ran through 2020. right
now he's a free agent gotcha
so uh and may continue to be a free
agent but at least he has a super bowl
ring and many other great quarterbacks
who
are in the hall of fame do not which is
just uh one of the sad realities
of the nfl plenty of guys out there who
contributed very little
to a super bowl effort still have a
super bowl ring that's probably the only
way i would ever get one in any way
shape or form
is to be at some low level job with a
team
right place right time and i got i re i
want one way or another i'm gonna have a
super bowl ring before i die even if i
have to buy it off at ebay
even if it's a cheap knockoff right even
if
even if it is hotter than the surface of
the sun i'm gonna find one
some way somehow i hear you it's a goal
of mine i mean it was a goal of mine i
don't know if it's uh
it's prevalent anymore aren't you
getting one of phil's
why aren't you getting the one from you
both 25 the one he didn't earn
you're right no i i would hope that goes
to my younger brother
i should get the one the first one super
bowl 21 that's the one i should get i
was there for it
you know my brother and sister were you
know my sister was two years old my
brother wasn't even born yet but um
i do have his super bowl mvp watch he's
already given me that
which is a very special thing i wear it
on our sunday night show from time to
time
that that's his way of telling you you
ain't getting one of the rings he's got
three kids maybe not
you got the super bowl mvp watch and
your brother's getting 20
at 21 and your sister's getting 25. it's
all in the family so don't worry and
my brother got some he got he got a few
other things too so don't worry don't
feel too sorry for him he's okay
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports